dans le livre révolution qu'il écrivait
juste avant d'être élu président de la
république
emmanuel macron disait ceci aujourd'hui
des français ont l'impression que leur
gouvernement ne gouverne plus le
rappeler par qui les marchés les
sondages la rue il existe une confusion
sur le détenteur du pouvoir
quand il n'ya pas de clarté des
gouvernements le peuple se cabre il faut
savoir expliquer plutôt que de faire de
la communication
une nouvelle étape de la déconcentration
de l'état est nécessaire
je crois dans un nouveau partage
démocratique c'est le fondement de la
république contractuelle dont nous avons
besoin à république qui fait confiance
aux territoires à la société et aux
acteurs pour se transformer les
collectivités locales et leurs élus
doivent jouer un rôle accru c'est une
nouvelle étape de transfert des pouvoirs
vers ces collectivités que nous vous
devons décider nous ne saurions mieux
dire monsieur le premier ministre au
moment où la crise des gis légende se
traduit par une rupture banale d'une
rupture brutale du lien de confiance
entre le peuple son président son
gouvernement
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi
depuis deux ans le président de la
république a fait très exactement le
contraire de ce que préconisait le
candidat macron enr centralisant
outrance toujours plus et en rejetant le
rôle prééminent des mères que vous
reprenez subitement en considération
pouvez vous êtes vous pète enfin prêt à
mettre en oeuvre les conditions d'une
déconcentration de l'état comme vous
comme on le disait ainsi qu'une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation massive et
d'expérimentation faisant confiance aux
élus locaux et aux partenaires sociaux
comme vous le demander dans les
conférences le président du sénat qui
est dans la constitution un garant de
l'équilibré des pouvoirs et des terry
par maaf êtes vous prêts à changer
radicalement de méthode en agissant du
bas vers le haut et non plus du haut
vers le bas pour éviter que votre grand
débat ne se transforme en grande débâcle
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
je ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur daubresse vous
remercier de votre question parce que ça
permet au delà de la lecture qui sont
les vôtres et des citations vous faites
de peut-être redire
et re préciser ce qu'est la politique du
gouvernement et notamment dans le grand
débat à vrai dire on a vu d'ailleurs je
trouve un exercice mardi dernier avec le
président de la république avec les
maires qui était un exercice qui a
démontré pour ceux qui pouvaient en
douter y compris parmi certains
manifestants le rôle des mères et leur
capacité à saisir la situation leur
territoire et à être les représentants
de leur territoire le gouvernement
depuis qu'il est installé il a envoyé un
certain nombre de messages alors
peut-être n'ont-ils pas été assez perçu
le premier c'est la monsieur daubresse
vous avez été maire d'une grande commune
lambersart je suis a été maire d'une
commune un peu plus au sud de ce
département et donc nous partageons
cette connaissance je crois et cet amour
des territoires et des collectivités
locales et donc le gouvernement avait
décidé alors que pendant les cinq années
précédentes et dotations avait baissé
fortement de stabiliser les dotations
mais c'était un signal c'est peut-être
pas la question mais c'était un signal
de confiance qui avaient été faits au
tac aux collectivités et aussi peut-être
même si ça peut être mal perçu au
travers de la contractualisation la
deuxième chose c'est que le gouvernement
essaie le texte que nous aurons à
débattre même s'il a été reporté et le
président la république devant le
congrès des maires en 2017 avait indiqué
qu'il souhaitait qu'une nouvelle étape
de la décentralisation super avec le
droit à la différenciation quoi de mieux
que le droit à la différenciation pour
permettre aux collectivités de se saisir
des choses et puis le troisième point
parce que le président de la république
en a parlé au maire nous étions plutôt
collectivement me semble-t-il est
compris dans les associations d'élus a
pensé qu'il fallait opérer une pause sur
les grandes réformes territoriales qui
avait donné un sentiment un peu de
tourbillon aux uns et aux autres
ceci étant à l'expérience et à
l'expérience que vous avez que nous
avons tous on voit bien qu'il ya une
question autour de la loi notre autour
des périmètres autour des compétences et
cela aussi le président de la république
a déclaré qu'il se déclarerait ouvert à
des débats des ajustements pas pour tout
refonder une fois de plus mais pour
répondre aux exigences pratiques des
mers et c'est bien ça qui sera l'enjeu
aussi du grand débat merci second run
oui messieurs messieurs min zhu
comprendrait au vu de ce que j'ai lu
qu'on prof préfère les preuves d'amour
aux déclarations d'amour nous attendons
une grande conférence territoriale
après le grand débat et une grande
conférence sociale nous attendons une
loi de décentralisation et nous
attendons que vous mettiez en pratique
les choses en respectant le sénat qui
est quand même la première assemblée
désignée par la constitution pour
représenter les collectivités
territoriales
merci la parole est à notre collègue